иностранный
[Музыка]
[Музыка
] хорошо, привет и добро пожаловать всем,
это прямая трансляция Actinf номер 47.0,
это 3 августа 2022 года,
добро пожаловать в институт активного вывода,
мы представляем собой совместную онлайн-лабораторию и
институт, который занимается обучением
и практикует прикладной активный вывод, который
вы можете  найдите нас по некоторым ссылкам
на слайде,
это записано, заархивировано,
расшифровано и опубликовано в прямом эфире,
поэтому, пожалуйста, предоставьте нам отзыв,
чтобы мы могли улучшить нашу работу
, приветствуются все предпосылки и точки зрения,
и мы будем следовать
видеоэтикету в прямом эфире.  потоки
все активные действия института логического вывода
являются совместными, поэтому дайте
нам знать, если вы хотите внести свой вклад или принять
участие,
перейдите на activeinference.org и щелкните ссылки,
чтобы принять непосредственное участие и узнать
больше,
мы собираемся отправиться на
нечетный
и уникальное приключение в 47.
мы собираемся обсудить и
сопоставить не одну статью, как обычно,
а подход с открытыми глазами
Что касается двух статей в этой ситуации, мы будем изучать и обсуждать в сопоставлении две статьи об активном выводе и похищении в 2021 году, написанные
Ати Вайко Питереном и Маджидом Бени, а
также мы будем обсуждать активное
динамическое социальное познание и активный
вывод Инес.  Hippolyto и thomas
van s также из 2021 года,
все видео с
точками и нулями и прочее являются
введением в эти идеи и
дополнительным контекстом, а не обзором,
оценкой или окончательным словом,
и мы собираемся
последовательно, мы надеемся, использовать эту
окраску светло-красного цвета для абдуктивной бумаги
и  светло-голубой для неактивных,
оставляя пространство открытым для появления новых цветов
и комбинаций, которые
демонстрируют некоторые области синтеза,
и мы собираемся поговорить в этой нулевой точке
с некоторыми важными вопросами и пройтись по нашим
целям, а также прочитать между этими
целями  который немного отличается
от многих прямых трансляций,
а затем мы предоставим
обзорную информацию по каждой газете с
точки зрения целей, заявленных в роа.  dmap
и реферат,
затем мы перейдем к предыстории в
разделе контекста,
который будет включать много информации
о семиотике бездействия, абдуктивной логике
и т. д.
Затем мы перейдем к
сопоставлению двух статей,
и у нас будет  много времени, чтобы
обсудить с, надеюсь, несколькими авторами
в предстоящих
дискуссиях.
начальное сопоставление и
просмотр этих документов, которые снова
просто заставят кого-то заинтересоваться чтением
документов, погрузиться в них более глубоко и поделиться
своей точкой зрения на эти
очень интересные темы,
поэтому
мы перейдем к введениям
я Даниэль я  исследователь в
Калифорнии,
и я расскажу больше о том, что интересно,
на следующих слайдах, я передам это
декану,
доброе утро, меня зовут декан, я в
Калгари, и я думаю, что я был,
возможно,  извращенный ум, который пытался
собрать эту идею воедино и, возможно,
немного изменить то, как мы смотрим
на активный вывод, пытаясь вытащить
две разные статьи, кажущиеся,
казалось бы,
разными народными фокусами,
а затем
оба из них также
включают использование активных
выводов.  в качестве методологии
для ситуационного анализа, и
каковы последствия для этого,
так что я нахожу это действительно захватывающим,
и я передам это Стивену,
так что спасибо, декан, да, Стивен здесь, я
в гм, Торонто, Канада, гм,
и я  очень
заинтересован в обеих этих статьях,
потому что
они оба много говорят о
подходах к участию в целом и о том,
как люди взаимодействуют с миром,
так что вопросы, связанные с бездействием
, действительно актуальны, как и
статья о похищении, так что
хотя они оба совершенно разные
документы, они оба
говорят со мной довольно сильно, так что это действительно
интересно, поэтому я с нетерпением
жду возможности
исследовать это.  я работаю с
коллективным театром
психологии общественного
развития и многомасштабными
процессами развития, и я очень
рад просто видеть, как
этот научный подход
может ответить на
то, что можно было бы назвать практическим
вопросом участия, который я
Я смотрел на это, поэтому я передам его
Дэниелу,
отлично, спасибо вам обоим, и Дину еще
раз спасибо за многомесячное
путешествие,
много писем, месяцев
и сообщений, которые мы прошли,
потому что я надеюсь, что это будет
развернуто и включено в  способ, который
берет прямые трансляции
и виды материалов, над которыми мы работаем,
за пределы того, что мы
ушли,
и
в
духе этого я передам декану, чтобы
представить здесь некоторые из важных вопросов,
хорошо,
если вы собираетесь тянуть два  статьи, которые
, кажется, не
имеют чертовски много общего с точки зрения
их предмета, вам
придется подойти к этому немного под
другим углом, с точки зрения не только
выяснения того, что находится в статье, но и
как можно сравнить эти документы,
поэтому мы собрали несколько
вопросов, связанных с идеей
о том, какую роль в качестве инструмента ситуационного анализа
или
метода активного вывода может играть активное умозаключение
в
вытягивании вещей, которые кажутся
далекими друг от друга, и в их запутывании,
и так далее.  в основном вопросы были
такими: может ли активный вывод быть одновременно
чем-то, что удерживает, содержит или
ограничивает что-то, а также может быть вещь,
ограниченная или захваченная, что такое активный
вывод или если что, если активный акцент,
как на
содержащемся
объекте, так и на строке разделителя в таблице
и  ячейка,
так что фактический пробел, в котором мы можем на
самом деле поместить больше информации в то
, как это выглядит, как это будет выглядеть
как ограничение и разделитель
одновременно, и я думаю, что это та
часть взаимности, которую мы собираемся
попытаться выявить в  следующие несколько прямых
трансляций и что похоже или отличается
в понимании
моделей и другого процесса,
который моделирует,
спасибо, Стивен, ты хочешь  я не могу добавить
что-нибудь сюда
нет, я думаю, что
это охватывает многое, единственное,
что этот x, который там есть, это своего рода
обозначение, как
вы знаете, могут ли активные модели вывода
моделировать
фреймворки um, так что эта
контекстуализация термина um вроде
входит в  играть, но мы поговорим
об этом чуть позже, так что да, спасибо,
круто, и
это
один из потенциально первых слайдов с нашими целями,
потому
что мы надеемся, что он поможет
вернуться на этот уровень.
Мем
здесь представляет эту прямую трансляцию,
объединяющую
две газеты так, что
одна рука хлопала в ладоши,
теперь мы собираемся объединить это в
две, вы уже можете слышать звук, исходящий
из прямой трансляции, особенно если
вы слушаете
Дина, что бы вы описали о
rames  или как бы вы
подытожили, о, и еще одно замечание, которое я
добавлю о rna ames, мы хотим, чтобы оно было
всеобъемлющим, но также имело видео,
которые можно слушать и иметь разумную
временную продолжительность, чтобы было много
скользящих  es, в котором будет много текста,
скопированного из бумаги, и будет просто
приостановка видео, если вы хотите
прочитать, но мы просто собираемся перейти
от многих текстовых слайдов, которые мы
действительно хотели убедиться, что  весь
текст был там невидимым, но мы не
собираемся читать все, поэтому,
пожалуйста, декан, подытожьте, о какой из этих
целей вы хотели бы
поговорить, вы знаете, я просто собираюсь
поговорить о
виде корня каждой  одна из этих пуль,
которая более подробно рассматривает
дебаты об инструментальном инструменте реализма, мне не нужно вдаваться в то, что
это такое, если вы были участником этого,
вы знаете, что мы описываем,
укрепите подход с двумя открытыми глазами
где один глаз воспринимает пару
активных умозаключений о неактивном
динамическом социальном условии
и похищении, в то время как другой человек, если
другой глаз проявляет активные умозаключения
как интегратор обоих,
потому что мы думаем, что он на самом деле может сделать
это, не смешиваясь,
он действительно может вызвать  ткать или  косы,
а затем третий пункт —
указать на абсолютную необходимость, если мы
собираемся сделать первые две вещи
понимания временной глубины
моделей, которые на самом деле
включали бы
две статьи по кажущимся далеким
темам, когда мы делаем активные выводы по
двум разным предметам
и  то, что мы сделали, это
вытащили разные
вещи, которые авторы отметили в
своих статьях,
спасибо и Стивен, если бы вы могли продолжить
чтение между этими целями
или добавить что-нибудь, что вы хотели бы из этого
слайда,
да, спасибо, Дэниел, так что
вы знаете один  группа авторов говорит, что вы
знаете, что на самом деле смотрите на
инструментализм,
и вы знаете, что знаете, что это достоверная
научная точка зрения, но вы знаете, что
там есть, а затем описываете, что знаете
этот вопрос о пути к
гм
реализму
и нормализму, поэтому
вы знаете,
в чем заключается идея, что в
одна работа, которой является инструментализм, -
это способ как бы
уловить или как
бы удержать себя в этой
научной работе,
которая может  быть оспорен,
и мы бы увидели способы, которые нам
могут понадобиться,
чтобы ослабить это, когда мы переходим
к подходам с участием, так что что-то среднее
между тем, что ослабляет это научное
пространство и является практическим пространством, так что то
же самое со вторым пунктом,
где все в порядке,  инструментализм,
хм, вы знаете путь вперед, так что же
представляет собой
поведение при жизни в нише, что
представляет собой живые существа,
хм, и как мы решаем,
какой путь вперед, так что, если
есть противоречия,
мы должны их примирить, если мы в
команде пытаемся  использовать это,
хм, мы должны просто жить с ними и
просто двигаться вперед,
хм, или где мы должны на самом деле выделить
их, так что это в некотором роде попытка
мыслить хм за пределами, может быть, такого рода
лазерного фокуса
на научной
философской точке и говорить хорошо, когда
мы пытаемся привести их в командный
контекст,
если бы мы ослабили некоторые из них
так
и так просто здесь упоминается, чтобы
подать заявку, если мы также
подумаем  насчет
активных импринтов с предисловием или
суффиксом, вы знаете, адаптивное активное
влияние, эффективное активное влияние или
моделирование активного вывода,
вы знаете, насколько важно это
разъяснение, чтобы затем
также подумать о том, как инструментальный
реализм может быть
использован другими способами
, нам нужно позиционировать  гм,
вы знаете полностью в одном, полностью в другом,
и если мы находимся между ними,
вы знаете,
может ли быть больший или меньший доступ к
знаниям, основанный на контексте, так часто в
совместной работе
различные типы практик, которые вы знаете,
контекст является ключевым,
а затем такого рода  немного говорит
о моем собственном представлении о совместном
творчестве, и я знаю, что
вы знаете, что Даниэль очень много работает с командами
и
деканами, очень много с трансформацией, вы
знаете, часто там есть часть совместного творчества,
там есть немного, где вы
вы хотите поддержать бабочку,
не раздавив ее, там есть что-то
очень хрупкое,
так как же мы можем
время от времени
приносить это в места, где это
о-творческое пространство, вы знаете, где
моделирование происходит более тонким
контекстуальным образом,
и
хотя у нас есть эти
научные определения, стратегические
проекты и тщательный анализ,
и они полезны, мы не хотим, чтобы они
разрушали то, что происходит,
и есть пара  там есть фотографии,
которые
говорят об этом, и я передам
это декану, может быть, и вы можете поговорить о
пробах воды между ними и разуме о
разрыве,
ну, я думаю, я думаю,
что это было прекрасное объяснение, и я
думаю,
когда, если и  когда авторы смогут
приехать, это будет что-то, что
мы теперь сможем раскрасить, я думаю, что
мы сделали, я думаю, что мы заложили несколько якорей в
землю, но мы не сказали,
сколько сколько потока
может проходить между этими разными узлами, и это
то, что, я думаю, мы хотели
установить прямо здесь, это промежуточность
много раз,
как говорится, обратите внимание на разрыв, это
единственное, что может убить вас в
метро,
ому что вы не обращаете вн
мания на  га  p, и я думаю, что
выборка воды между ними делает
то же самое, за исключением того, что она обеспечивает
немного другую
тонкую разницу с точки зрения
текучести этих видов промежутков, поэтому я
думаю, что было бы действительно интересно, если
бы мы использовали это как наш портал  в том, как
мы могли бы собрать вещи вместе и
заставить их
танцевать, когда в противном случае они
сидели бы на стульях в противоположной
стороне комнаты, что может быть интересным
разговором, чтобы начать с точки один и
два,
спасибо вам обоим, и единственный комментарий, который я буду
добавьте сюда
это обсуждение, которое мы провели по
прилагательным, которые
предшествуют адаптивному аффективному и т. д. активному
выводу,
а затем также акцентировали внимание
на суффиксе, который x и
заключает в скобки
активную модель вывода как один экземпляр
или случай или реализацию
активного вывода
теория процесса активного вывода, что
следует за этим, и это действительно напоминает мне о предложениях
левого и правого ветвления
в грамматике и синтаксисе,
а также о том, что есть основа c  lause,
что является нашим базовым предложением, а затем какие
ответвления до, во время и после я думаю, что
есть очень богатое пространство, и мне очень
нравятся эти воплощенные
и основанные на потоках метафоры, которые помогают нам
понять
так много, что
в обзорах бумаги
это будут просто некоторые метаданные и
описания документов, прежде чем мы
вернемся к фону в контексте,
а затем перейдем к документам,
просматривая их основные моменты,
поэтому мы не будем читать аннотации,
они оба,
конечно, доступны для этих статей,
вот аннотация для  активный
вывод и абдукция
вот реферат для неактивного динамического
социального познания и активного вывода
вот ключевые слова для обеих этих
статей в неактивной статье
есть ключевые слова построение ниши социального познания
активный вывод теория разума и
активизм и теория динамических систем
статья абдукции имеет  ключевые слова
абдукция активный вывод принцип свободной энергии
первый и общий
триадические отношения и прокалывание
давайте перейдем к целям
и утверждениям
документа о похищении,
так что,
декан, не могли бы вы осветить
любую из целей документа о похищении,
что я хотел бы сделать, это просто как бы
предсказать, к чему
стремятся оба документа, и
что  вы увидите ключевое слово во
втором пункте этой статьи, а именно «
союз», а затем есть слова, которые
вы увидите в другой статье,
где они снова говорят, что
мы хотим, чтобы все сошлось,
но мы хотим  будьте осторожны с тем, как мы
описываем это сближение, мы не
хотим, чтобы это воспринималось метафорически
как смешение как уничтожение
двух двух или более вещей, которые, как мы верим,
имеют
ассоциативную связь, и поэтому я думаю, что когда
вы проходите через  цели двух
статей, если вы немного отступите назад,
вы увидите, что
авторы обеих статей
делают жесткое объяснение того, на какие
отношения
они хотят, чтобы мы обратили внимание, и это
то, что они оба  Бумаги
разделяют это тяжелое внимание  Замечательная идея об
отношениях,
и они оба очень
богато и мощно написаны,
и здесь мы видим союз и верность,
и, конечно же,
в обеих статьях будет много дискуссий об
интеграции разрозненных или частично
связанных онтологий и словарных наборов,
а также о разных мыслителях, разных нитях.
об интеллектуальном развитии,
эти цитаты из статьи могут быть прочитаны
и, конечно, расширены в
статье,
но, как сказал декан, в этой статье основное внимание
уделяется интеллектуальному союзу
между активным выводом и принципом свободной энергии
fep и, в первую очередь, работе
CS Pierce
с точки зрения  семиотика, прагматика,
грамматика, абдуктивная логика, которая является
целью синтеза, объединяет эти два
понятия синергетическим образом
и дает смысл
посмотреть на
области, которые действительно трудно
смоделировать для компьютеров, хм и
То, как происходит похищение, или, в
частности, с людьми,
очень сложно, и я думаю,
что это действительно полезно, чтобы затем увидеть
семиотику, которая на самом деле много используется
в
театральной сонографии и дизайне декораций.
это, как вы знаете, выходит за рамки
науки, часто верно, часто используется в
других областях, например,
в естественных науках это используется,
но часто используется в гуманитарных науках, поэтому
я думаю, что
это говорит о том,
что это такое,
что раскрывается, такой секретный соус
такого рода удар в душу, который
обычно отсутствует, и в
действии также есть что-то вроде того, что
потрясающие
утверждения
статьи повсюду в статье, но просто для того, чтобы
выделить некоторые из ключевых утверждений, которые
они утверждают, что та цель, которую они
поставили перед собой  сделать
между работой активного вывода
и абдукции и семиотической точки
зрения, они утверждают, что это
осуществимо, и что они обеспечивают
начальную  набросок для этого
в этой теоретической
интеграции нового и старого
что-то красное что-то синее что-то
новое что-то старое
и две рамки, новое и
старое соответственно,
являются современными реализациями
нейронауки и когнитивной науки,
представленными принципом свободной энергии
и на основе  старый исторически точная
и точная интерпретация абдуктивного
вывода, включая
важность экономики исследований, все вещи, к которым
мы собираемся вернуться, просто
хотели прояснить утверждения, могу ли я просто
добавить одно да, пожалуйста,
очень быстро, так что теоретическая интеграция
здесь я  Это означает, что, если вы можете
вернуться к тому времени, когда мы говорили о наших
целях,
теперь вопрос в том, что
авторы говорят,
что нам интересно, делает ли это
активный вывод как о продукте интеграции, так
и об интеграторе, о процессе,
и снова я  хочу, я хочу как бы
дразнить этот шаг назад, потому что я думаю,
что это произойдет снова, когда мы
посмотрим  в другой газете
они будут использовать другую номенклатуру, но
они будут говорить одно и то же, и
снова
трудно увидеть общие черты,
если только вы и вам не нужно
их придумывать,
вы просто должны
замечать их
в тексте.  два разных типа лесов
и пункт о том, что они
оба используют активный вывод
как интегратор, а также как
дифференциатор; мы создаем
интегрированную модель внутренних и
внешних и общих состояний
, дифференцируя их, а затем,
конечно, интегрируя  и дифференцирование
также имеют совместное
использование в математике с интегральной
и производной нотацией, так что
будет много вещей, которые сойдутся
вместе, эм,
Стивен, ваши руки все еще подняты, да, пожалуйста,
да, еще только одна вещь, я думаю,
это действительно полезно поговорить о
неврология в этой вычислительной
нейробиологии и подчеркнуть это,
потому что я думаю,
что что-то, что
является реальностью в мире,
культура там,
где эти идеи  циркулирует
то, что
нейробиология переворачивается с ног на голову в основном
активным влиянием
нейробиологии как области,
поскольку люди понимают, что
это
своего рода
дедуктивный процесс поступления информации, а затем
ее оценки и
конкретизации, в отличие от этого
предсказательного путешествия, поэтому я думаю, что это
действительно очень полезно
потому что это то, с чем
мы все сталкиваемся, и я думаю, что я также
отметил, когда разговаривал с некоторыми
нейробиологами, что у них действительно
был экзистенциальный кризис, и они
часто менялись частично, выдвигая неактивные
заявления и видя, действительно ли  есть неактивные
заявления, как может их работа с
неврологией быть
настолько сплоченной, так
что здесь есть часть,
которая относится к общему, и
что эта общая
часть более важна,
когда мы начинаем приносить
активное влияние
из специальных областей.  где он как бы
анклав и его правила игры
известны, и вы находитесь в областях, где
люди хорошо говорят о нейронауке  я знаю, что
это значит,
и вперед, так что большое спасибо,
в документе относительно мало разделов, в
нем есть введение
, а затем представлено
сочетание активного вывода в свете
похищения
похищения в свете активного
вывода
слегка косвенная ссылка ни на что в
биология имеет смысл, кроме как
в свете эволюции или в свете
чего-то, и это два света
назад к тем островам, что является пространством
между ними,
а затем идет
обсуждение экономики исследований и натурализации их свободной
энергии, а также заключение
и  протыкать кроличьи норы глубоко,
мы собираемся перейти к нескольким в ближайшее
время в неактивном документе,
поэтому здесь мы собираемся описать
утверждения Эймса и дорожную карту неактивного
динамического социального познания и активного
логического вывода,
документ представляет собой двух-  Сложите
цель проанализировать новые версии,
которые сочетаются в активизме с выводами,
и объяснить, почему это
приводит к противоречию,
является первой
целью и  Конечная цель состоит в том, чтобы
предложить единственную разумную учетную запись, связанную с
активизмом и выводными учетными записями,
особенно в этом случае социального
познания,
так что
да, пожалуйста, не догадайтесь, на что я надеялся,
не могли бы вы теперь сделать слово, связывающее
фиолетовым для нас,
да,
спасибо,
у нас есть разные способы  описывая
между тем, что Стивен проделал прекрасную работу
по подчеркиванию, прежде чем мы на самом деле
начали смотреть на
сами документы,
да, это между ними, да,
это потрясающе, и на самом деле
благодаря вашему запросу и платформе слайдов
это становится активным динамическим
социальным стигматизмом
и так далее.
это доказательство концепции чего,
но это и есть цели этой статьи, хорошо, у
них также есть много заявлений,
сформулированных в ходе обсуждения,
и они на самом деле используют некоторые очень четкие
обозначения для описания конкретных утверждений
из другой работы и из своей собственной работы
и о том, какие утверждения  и гипотезы
имеют какое логическое отношение
они собираются делать заявления о
природе познания и его  воплощенной
основе,
они будут обсуждать
некоторые утверждения, связанные с социальной
когнитивной нишей человека,
и говорить о важности
построения ниши инкультурации отношений,
а затем они будут говорить
о теории разума
и о совместимости или
противоречиях.
связанный со связью
неактивных
утверждений с
теорией разума или логическими выводами
,
дорожная карта статьи довольно четко излагает многие из этих целей и
утверждений, они начинаются с
введения
и представляют
недавнюю, хотя и влиятельную работу в
области активного вывода, которая представляет собой
структуру мышления через другие умы
ttom,
и они, как они говорят, анализируют это
объяснение,
чтобы попытаться разобрать способ, которым, по
их
мнению, были сведены вместе неактивные и логические подсчеты.
их статьи,
раздел 2, что-то должно дать,
отвергая неактивный вывод t  через
другие умы
они будут использовать два предположения,
а именно, что социальное познание сводится к
ментальному представлению, и два, что
социальное познание запрограммировано с рождения,
и они будут не согласны с
обоими этими предположениями и в своем
противодействии этим предположениям,
поддерживаемым дополнительными утверждениями.  и доказательства,
которые приведут их к
более широким выводам,
они будут использовать теорию динамических систем
и говорить о том, как dst
может быть связано с активизмом с точки
зрения его совместимости, и что эти две
концепции предлагают друг другу в
инструменталистском прочтении
и  затем они собираются обсудить активный
вывод конкретно в контексте
теории динамических систем, с одной стороны, и
неактивное
познание, социальное познание, с другой
стороны, это неактивный динамический
перенос, который
они описывают несколькими цифрами
о сходствах и различиях
между социальным бездействием в целом.  как
концептуализировано вне активного
вывода, а затем они  мы собираемся
представить визуально, как активный вывод
обогащает эту картину,
а затем у них есть очень интересная
таблица, в которой проводится различие между
явлениями, наблюдаемыми в естественном мире,
и наблюдаемым поведением в естественном
мире.
предыстория в разделе контекста,
поэтому в этом разделе нулевой точки
мы обязательно будем
использовать некоторые цитаты из статьи,
но мы также собираемся сделать шаг назад
и продемонстрировать только верхушку
айсберга стипендий и
исследований.  которые мы выполнили
до этого момента,
надеюсь, чтобы
возбудить слушателя или читателя
и обеспечить некоторый контекст в этих
очень глубоких нитях, которые будут рассмотрены
и приближены в
статьях,
я предоставлю первое примечание здесь или декан,
пожалуйста, перейдите на  это
просто я думаю, я думаю, что это
захватывающий момент, чтобы сказать,
хорошо, так что
предыстория и контекст, поэтому мы говорим,
может быть,
временная и физическая
обстановка,
так что  Теперь это то, что мы можем
ситуационно проанализировать,
и опять
же, не имеет значения, используете ли вы активный
вывод, используете ли вы
модель приведения или используете ли вы
профессиональные инициативы.
метод и и и
я полагаю, что каждый из этих
методов
имеет большую или меньшую жизнеспособность в
зависимости от того, какова ситуация как во
времени, так и физически,
поэтому я думаю,
что это важные вещи, которые мы не
говорим, что каждая из этих
статей хороша или плоха.
мы говорим, что каждая из этих
статей фокусируется на разных
комбинациях фонового контекста минимум
из двух, поэтому теперь, если мы объединим две вещи,
мы не можем сказать
, что это будет то же
самое, что мы собираемся сделать.  придумать,
что наши цели как люди, которые теперь
посмотрели на две статьи рядом друг с другом,
которые собираются создать совершенно новую
сущность,
спасибо, что
вы привели этот фон и
контекст  tualizing section Я хотел
сослаться на одного из моих любимых поэтов-ремесленников
Уильяма Блейка,
а Блейк написал, что
противоположности являются положительными отрицание
не является противоположным
отрицания не являются противоположностями противоположности
существуют взаимно,
но отрицания существуют не
исключения и возражения и неверия
не существуют и никогда не будут
организованы  Навсегда и навсегда
конец цитаты
противоречия в этой блэкианской четырехчастной
логической структуре
на самом деле
являются частью диалектики, и они существуют
как функции друг друга, как выпуклость
и вогнутость или как гравитация и
излучение, как мог бы это сделать Бакминстер Фуллер,
и, таким образом, отрицания в этом поэтическом
рамки
- это те, которые
не существуют,
тогда как а и b могут быть, наоборот,
тогда как а и не а имеют разные
логические отношения, и этот вид
четырехчастного логического подхода
к распознаванию пространства состояний и
истины утверждает, что множественные сопоставленные
утверждения могут иметь с
между
собой также предвидится во многих мировых
традициях познания
um fo  например, ката Скотти,
и это логический
инструмент и метод, который применялся в
течение очень долгого времени в дхармических
традициях индийского контекста, которые
хотели предоставить это, а
также эти образы, которые любой из
вас может исследовать.
аплодирует ли одна рука или человек,
делающий шпагат,
имеет отношение к противоречию и
отрицанию
да, декан, да,
относительно противоречия, и я
думаю, что это
указывает
на вид контекстной части,
эм,
ситуационной
части анализа
, есть ситуация,
внутри которой
противоречия создаются, если это
имеет смысл,
хм, и это также воплощено и разыграно
в нашей жизни, так что это вполне может быть
в младенчестве, как вы знаете,
морфология ребенка на
разных
стадиях в разных контекстах дает
способы
установить ситуационные
осознание
и противоречия внутри этого,
поскольку вещи кодифицируются, поэтому у вас есть
эти
эти ситуационные
гм
процессы - это то, что мы
делаем в этом продолжающемся потоке моделирования,
какие области практики
в этих различных статьях, которые их поддерживают,
инактивист чувствует практику
или хм, чем больше у них вычислительных областей
практики, они  то, что мы как бы
воплощаем, и во что мы входим, и мы учимся,
и это то, что мы как бы
интуитивно моделируем таким образом, чтобы мы
чувствовали, как мы должны моделировать
в этих ситуациях противоречия,
но это моделирование
часто, и это опасность,
когда  это
подавляется кем-то со своей моделью,
то есть кто-то в своем мире моделирует,
каково это быть собой, или пытается
обработать это, они идут и видят консультанта
со своей моделью, и эта
модель используется, чтобы подогнать их к модели,
а затем этот консультант  расскажет нам, в
чем их проблема, как она оформлена, поэтому
я думаю, что эта модель модели
вполне уместна здесь, потому что вы знаете, как
только эти противоречия будут
установлены, вполне может быть, что
есть мо  del создается в этом
домене,
а затем кто-то, кто не обязательно находится
в этом домене,
может
быть отнесен к модели, они не знают,
что такое игра, они не
участвуют в процессе, и модель берет верх, так что
это как бы переключается на разделение
потому что тогда ладно, у нас есть две вещи,
они вместе,
мы говорим об этом, да, давай
ты откроешься, и у тебя есть позиция,
хорошо, так что я немного, и в какой-то момент
это похоже на то, что это не позиция, брат
, это  это раскол, в который вы попали
, вам нужно быть осторожным,
правильно, поэтому вы вошли в эту идею, что
вы открываете вещи сейчас, были ли они
одной вещью для начала, были ли они той
позицией, которую они удерживали  в каком-то смысле
они разделились таким образом,
что теперь они
изолированы друг от друга, вы знаете, я
полагаю, мы пытаемся найти
способ ни столкнуть их в одно,
ни разделиться, может быть, занять
промежуточную позицию между
этим  как-то проворно и
относится в данном случае к реализму и
трументализм, который как бы перекликается с некоторыми
более широкими темами,
спасибо, декан,
просто очень быстро, многие люди
слышали баронизм йогов, когда вы
видите развилку на дороге,
возьмите ее, и я знаю, что с
большим количеством термина «косяк
» пришел  например, много совместных вероятностей,
и поэтому идея разделения
здесь действительно хороша, если говорить метафорически,
потому что,
если вы
смотрите на что-то с активными
помехами и предполагаете, что
в эксперименте с чайным лабиринтом вам нужно идти
влево или вправо хорошо  люди
могут увидеть развилку на дороге и взять ее
, это своего рода шутка,
если вы видите развилку в моих ногах, возьмите их
, не обязательно
выбирать орби, вы можете
взять все, и я думаю, что это то, что
Блейк  пытается указать этим
упражнением, и поэтому это противоречие
нет, если я увижу посуду на дороге, я могу
взять ее, но если я не согласен
с идеей, что вилка не означает только
влево или вправо,
тогда я  уже самоограничен с точки
зрения wh  в я тестирую то, что я
ситуационно проанализировал,
спасибо вам обоим в более
прямых ключевых
словах, поэтому в действии с
сайта thisdefinitions.net действие является одним из возможных
способов организации знаний и
форм взаимодействия с миром
неактивных знаний  это знание, которое
приходит через действие и строится
на двигательных навыках, таких как манипулирование
объектами при езде на велосипеде или занятия
спортом, это лишь одно из многих
определений, которые были предоставлены,
у нас также было несколько прямых трансляций и
бумажных обсуждений действий в активном
выводе
например
в активном прямом эфире номер
шесть назад, когда в 2020 году мы обсуждали
рамстед вообще сказку о двух плотностях
активный вывод есть активный вывод
в
2021 году мы обсуждали статью тоже
гипполита вообще воплотили искусное
исполнение где действие
и интересно
для  в некотором роде это самое
обсуждение, вот слайд из
этой прямой трансляции, гм,
гм, гм, из газеты гипполита
и  здесь у нас была пронзительная
триада, и у нас была символика
, семиотика и отсылки к
французскому языку,
так что мы на самом деле говорили о
очень родственной концепции репрезентации
и действительно о тех, кто поддерживает
, или отвергает, или находит противоречие
и взаимосвязь всех  приведенное
выше обсуждение
инактивизма и логических выводов
будет во многом зависеть от
вопроса о репрезентации и когнитивных
репрезентациях, что это такое, где
они, существуют ли они и т. д.,
гм, это было в прямом эфире 23.
также из этой статьи о сангати вообще,
они  просто визуально, мы
скоро увидим больше репрезентаций,
с их точки зрения,
некоторые различия между
традиционным социальным познанием
и неактивным социальным познанием,
и поэтому, а не просто визуальная
интерпретация имени изображения, сочтите
, вы хотели бы предоставить его
нет, я жду, чтобы  вы вниз в следующем хорошо,
так что здесь, что я вижу, так это то, что в
традиционных социальных когнитивных логических
выводах шестеренки  вращаются внутри мозга,
а затем есть петли действия восприятия
и связи, которые соединяют социальные
сущности, которые находятся в их теле, но
тело рассматривается как интерфейс
для такого рода передачи информации,
одна крайняя позиция или простое визуальное
представление,
а затем здесь, напротив, мы  видите,
что шестерни повсюду, в том числе в
окружающей среде в нише в
пространстве между ними,
и что да, мозг что-то делает,
но также он является частью разыгранной системы
, которая реализует этот культурный
социальный когнитивный процесс немного
больше в целостной структуре, поэтому  Дин, да,
да, я просто собирался сказать, что
через минуту мы посмотрим,
о чем говорит похищение, но
сейчас
я хотел бы, чтобы люди просто держали
в уме идею, что
это говорит с типом  временная
глубина, но эта временная глубина
вертикальна,
я думаю, что похищение, глядя на более длинные
временные шкалы в течение сотен лет, более
горизонтально, поэтому просто имейте в виду, что
мы  большая временная глубина, но
основное внимание уделяется вертикальной или глубокой
временной глубине, а не широкой латеральной
временной глубине,
обе они имеют значение, но они ортогональны,
это не означает, что они находятся в конфликте друг
с другом, это просто означает, что они
идут  в разных направлениях, вот и все, что
я хочу сказать о том, что
это забавно, лево и право или запад и
восток — это противоположные направления, но
они не отрицательные направления, и
именно здесь мы начинаем видеть,
как предоставляется ортогональность, или разреженность,
или условная независимость.
с помощью марковского одеяла, например,
как их можно увидеть в
рамках противоположностей, хотя и не отрицаний.
Стивен
и эта шестерня на правой
диаграмме там шестерня между ними,
вы знаете, что она может иметь временную глубину,
которая может иметь этот разум-тело
часть окружающей среды определенно присутствует, как вы
говорите, и, очевидно, представляет собой единицу
анализа, которая действительно сложна, и я
бы также добавил туда в качестве механизма слова
слова
дергаются
твич  Колдовство нашего голосового аппарата дает нам
слова в пространстве вокруг нас,
поэтому вы знаете, что они также используются в качестве инструментов
, поэтому внезапно
мы гораздо больше запутываемся, даже если это
просто речь,
да, и требуется время, чтобы речь
прошла через  Интернет и через
пространство и
время немного больше глубины социального
бездействия.
Этот исследовательский ресурс бездействия
описывает несколько значений и смыслов
бездействия
в перформативных и
порождающих смыслах, поэтому, пожалуйста, прочитайте,
а также действительно хорошую статью 2009 года по
когнитивной семиотике де Брюйна.  и де
хаан
обсуждают некоторые отношения
активизма в социальном познании,
и они проделали отличную работу,
подытоживая то, что
могут свести воедино логические и инактивистские подходы,
и как бы
обсудив эту связь.
и
вот что интересно, если они
собираются использовать метафору моста,
я думаю, что у активизма действительно есть мост,
это просто вертикальный мост,
это  сторона здания поднимается вверх,
и так что
ничего, кроме критики того, что
они здесь написали, но я думаю, что
есть долг,
и есть возможность перекрыть его,
просто он идет
вертикально, он не идет традиционно из
стороны в сторону,
круто,
так что  мы немного углубились в
абдукции и семиотику,
ну,
у нас было довольно много учебного пути
вместе,
и
статья о абдукции, в
которой
один, или полтора, или даже два
автора были настоящими экспертами по Пирсону,
предоставила много деталей,
Пирс был плодовитым писателем и мыслителем.
и соавтор, а также большая часть
работы не была опубликована, что означает, что
есть некоторые загадочные справочные системы,
и не все из них
гипердоступны, мы обнаружили, что сайт commons.org
чрезвычайно полезен для предоставления многих
определений, а также ссылок на
ресурсы, которые декан хотел бы  вам нравится
обобщать что-либо на этой странице,
не что иное, как если вы,
если вы заинтересованы в
прагматизме, и вы хотите пройти мимо
уильяма джеймса, на самом деле уильям  у джеймса и
чарльза сандерса пирса было что-то вроде того,
что они были, может быть, 150 лет назад они были
первыми
конфликтующими вокруг того, как все работает,
на самом деле это действительно удивительная
отправная точка с точки зрения того, как люди, которые,
кажется, соревнуются друг с
другом, на самом деле делают  друг друга
умнее, но на самом
деле многие идеи, которые мы 150 лет
спустя сейчас оглядываемся назад, мы должны
были бы сказать, что они, возможно, чувствовали, что
соревнуются друг с другом, но я думаю,
что то, что они делали, было передачей  или
каким-то образом построить лучшую модель, потому
что они не всегда смотрели на вещи
одними и теми же глазами, у них были открыты оба глаза,
так что я просто скажу, иди
на общий сайт, это действительно хорошо,
да, это здорово, это представление
иронически косая черта
уместно  относится к хорошо известной
семиотической структуре триады Пирсона, где
знак остановки называется репрезентативным,
представленным
экземпляром, физическим знаком
остановки, реальным знаком остановки,
объектом является беспорядок.  Возрастные автомобили должны остановиться
здесь, и интерпретация такова: я должен
остановиться здесь, и вот где мы получаем это
агентство сущностей.
Я нашел интересный документ
о пользовательском интерфейсе,
который переносит некоторые из этих действительно
вечных дискуссий о семиотике и
логике в цифровой контекст, который
они применяют.  этот семиозис для
метафоры пользовательского интерфейса
можно было бы представить, если бы это был знак остановки
в реальном мире или если бы это была
кнопка на веб-сайте в контексте пользовательского интерфейса,
и
любой мог бы сделать паузу и прочитать некоторые из
этих превосходных отрывков из цитат
и э-э
здесь много лекций
о том, как
копии знаков и символов связаны
посредством логики и семиозиса
, но мы продолжим
конкретно о похищениях, так что это было
немного о Пирсе и
определении семиотики в отличие
от науки о вещах, более позитивных
наук.  и наука о формах, которые
являются более формальными науками,
что такое абдуктивное рассуждение,
это было очень увлекательно исследовать
это цитата из abductio  В статье, которую
они написали, во вторичной
литературе распространено,
например, то, что, опираясь на пирс
, рассматривать похищение как происходящее из
двух частей или двух видов:
генеративное похищение и селективное
похищение,
вот еще один взгляд на два
типа или два сорта или два
компонента двухтактный двигатель
абдукции из стэнфордской энциклопедии
философии
они написали в философской
литературе термин абдукция используется в
двух родственных, но разных смыслах
в обоих смыслах термин относится к
объяснительному рассуждению
в исторически первом смысле он
относится
к месту объяснительного рассуждения в
порождении гипотез  это порождающая
абдукция, в то время как во втором смысле,
который чаще всего используется
в современной литературе, он
относится к месту объяснительного
рассуждения в обосновании или оценке
перечисленного набора гипотез
и в некотором смысле придает
смысл содержанию  должны быть сгенерированы для
курирования идеи должны быть конкретизированы  ied
перечислено для того, чтобы быть оправданным или
оцененным,
декан, пожалуйста, продолжайте в том
же духе, просто очень быстро, так
что теперь у нас есть красный и синий, что было
действительно важно, чтобы подчеркнуть,
что вам нужны оба, вам нужно как минимум
два, чтобы объяснение
появилось
следующим абдуктивным  рассуждение в
вероятностном смысле, также известное как
вывод о наилучшем объяснении, является
формой логического рассуждения, которая
рассматривает наиболее вероятную гипотезу для объяснения
чего-либо.
здесь мы
можем видеть, как выдвинутая гипотеза
зависит
от неполного наблюдения или
вывода, есть ли бобы также в
мешке, и даже если так, то источник
того, что было перенесено в
левую руку, так что снова временная глубина,
когда вы прибываете в  ситуация,
какой фон и
какой контекст у вас
есть, собирается перейти к этой четвертой
форме логики, которая или кошелек выглядят буквально  Вы
потратили всю жизнь,
пытаясь
распутать, а затем
преобразовать в какую-то связность,
и
те, кто слушает, могут начать видеть
намеки на априорные сенсорные наблюдения,
апостериорное обновление убеждений о
мире, даже выбор действия, вступающий в
игру, особенно перевод
аффордансов мгновенной
доступности  политики, которые
можно оценить по их ожидаемой свободной
энергии, но мы собираемся добраться туда,
давайте обратимся
к похищениям, и вот некоторые из
очень увлекательных статей, доступных на
общих основаниях, связанных с похищением, много там,
и как бы продолжим с одним
из  ресурсы из общин по
похищению как практический
вывод Томаса Капитана
эта работа, о
которой мы не собираемся читать все,
содержит множество интересных
моментов
о двойственной природе похищения
с созданием
гипотезы и выбором гипотезы
и различает, что выбор гипотезы
может сделать дедуктивно  действительные оценки,
однако этапы творчества  e
не является выводным, что имеет большой
резонанс с такими идеями, как отсутствие предварительной цензуры
и инклюзивное
обсуждение при мозговом штурме
и признание того, что должно быть
отсеивание в конечном периоде пространства
и времени,
кроме того, здесь есть некоторые обсуждения,
это было
Когда мы движемся назад к
принципу свободной энергии или переплетаемся с ним,
первоначальное осознание гипотезы
приходит с наблюдением
составного целого посредством
неконтролируемого проникновения в мир
идей, в то, что он называл третьестью, как
данное в восприятии,
новое понимание любого  пример
посылки 2,
цитирующей предыдущую часть статьи,
вызван предшествующими познаниями,
априорными
фактами, его содержание подсказывается фактами,
наблюдениями, сенсорными наблюдениями,
но не все предполагаемое выводится
из познания фактов,
и поэтому
Пирс продолжает описывать, что существуют
операции  разум, которые
логически в точности аналогичны
умозаключениям,
допускающим лишь то, что они необоснованны.  сознательным
и, следовательно, неконтролируемым и,
следовательно, не подлежащим критике, поэтому,
оставляя в стороне такие вопросы, как,
можно ли считать бессознательные процессы
контролируемыми,
мы очень часто видим намеки на
восприятие как бессознательные умозаключения, и
мы также видим непрерывность
между процессами внимания и
осознания,
сознательными умозаключениями
и другими подсознательными умозаключениями.  Таким образом,
в некотором смысле это также обеспечивает
интегрированную структуру восприятия,
изучения убеждений, обновления временной глубины,
сознательного и бессознательного осознания,
все эти особенности исследуются в
персидской работе, и документ о похищениях
будет очень конкретно
подчеркивать этот факт,
хорошо, продолжим немного.  немного больше,
э-э, похищение и ретродукция,
не могли бы вы добавить что-нибудь к
этому декану,
ну, я имею в виду людей, которые изучали это и
анализировали это
время от времени, интересно, было ли это
морфологией или нет, или мы можем
использовать два термина одновременно или
взаимозаменяемо
снова  это, наверное, один  из тех вещей,
где, если вы
хотите узнать подробности,
вам, вероятно, следует пойти и посмотреть,
потому что это интересно, но это не так.
процесс, при котором
из удивительного набора фактов мы приходим
к
предположению, мы использовали много предположений,
чтобы объяснить их, многие
логики отказываются называть этот последний
вывод,
потому что его вывод настолько
проблематичен, что представляет собой немногим больше,
чем вопрос
я уверен, что они ошибаются, однако они
не обладают
истинным научным
определением вывода, поэтому он в
основном говорит здесь, что давайте не будем
называть
абдуктивное рассуждение инфракрасным, эм,
индуктивным рассуждением,
логическим обоснованием
ретродукции, правильный
вывод которого состоит в том, что  предполагаемое
положение вещей, вероятно,
в смутном смысле имеет
тенденцию напоминать реальное
положение вещей, и именно в
этой части  на заменяет этот
инструментализм,
что бы мы ни определяли как
это снова одна из тех головоломок, если это
не так, если это не
реальное
состояние, это то, что не является тогда, что такое
нереальное или нереальное состояние, потому что оно
есть,
мы  обозначил это
тем, что наполняет, что чувствует, что в
конечном итоге сделать целое, вот в чем
здесь вопрос,
а также снова стоит прочитать некоторые
из предыдущих работ одного из авторов
статьи о похищении, и можно увидеть
в их исследованиях сильную линию
развития и  расширяя и
модернизируя большую часть работы,
давайте просто
да, поэтому я отложил эти знаки медведя,
потому что я хочу рассказать очень, очень,
очень короткую историю,
поэтому, если вы живете где-то, где есть
медведи, если знак медведя остается,
люди начинают игнорировать  фактический
объект знака,
и они больше не становятся интерпретаторами,
они намеренно
теряют эту триаду, поэтому,
если
вы занимаетесь защитой животных и не хотите, чтобы медведи слишком
привыкли к человеческому  человек, контактный человек, вы должны быть
очень избирательны, когда вы ставите знак
и, что наиболее важно, когда вы удаляете
знак,
поэтому я хотел поместить это там, потому
что это большая часть части похищения и
ретродукции,
вы должны иногда забирать вещи
для  Похищение для работы - это
устранение возможностей,
которые на самом деле
создают акцент,
я думаю, мы просто продолжим реализм
и инструментализм, потому что мы собираемся
вернуться к похищению в
последующих дискуссиях, поэтому
вот несколько цитат из статьи о честном изгибе.
согласно реализму, такое знание,
фактическое знание, описывает
общие или частные особенности
Вселенной, так что это не означает, что
моделью гравитации является гравитация, не означает,
что моделью гравитации являются
объекты гравитации,
но реалист  заметьте, что,
например, формальные модели гравитации учат
нас существованию
объектов, на которые действует сила гравитации,
и разрешают описание силы,
которая может  не быть непосредственно увиденным, услышанным или
осязаемым, но все же оказывающим заметное
влияние,
силы, реальны, вещи реальны
согласно инструментализму
, даже вполне верная теория
ничего не описывает, но
служит орудием для предсказания
фактов, составляющих ее эмпирическое
содержание,
и, следовательно,  Опять же, на этом
примере гравитации Ньютона инструменталисты
могли бы занять позицию, что не существует
сущностей,
гравитационная сила и гравитационные
поля
являются просто инструментальными
приложениями статистических
аргументов или, возможно, даже социальных или
силовых динамических аргументов,
и инструменталист может отрицать
существование объектов,
сущностей и сил в этом  случай
и даже довести вещи до
уровня скептицизма в отношении слов как
инструментов и отношений вокруг
коммуникации
и того, как она упорядочивает и предсказывает чувственные
данные.
номер в прямом эфире  14.
еще один слайд о реализме и
инструментализме, а затем кто-нибудь из вас,
пожалуйста, не стесняйтесь,
я снова опишу некоторые из нижних.
Различие территории на карте
очень
важно для разговора о реализме и инструментализме
. Также было множество отличных
философских работ
для  Например, преемник вопроса о реализме и
антиреализме,
эти два, кстати, я бы сказал, являются
отрицаниями, тогда как реализм и
инструментализм, которые
мы предлагаем, могут рассматриваться как
противоположности,
а также работа Хелен Лонгано о
научном плюрализме может многое сказать
об этом, взяв
междисциплинарная линза реализма и
инструментализма,
а затем декан, не могли бы вы описать
что-нибудь об этой главной статье, которую вы нашли,
э-э,
я могу, я не помню этого в
великих схемах, если честно, это здесь для
людей, чтобы прочитать было много статей
и  снова мы просто размещаем много
текста для тех, кто хочет сделать паузу и
пройтись по следам,
и все это как бы запутывается в
Стивене и  y комментарии о реализме,
инструментализме,
я полагаю, что часть, которая
мне часто приходит на ум, заключается в том, что
все это затем подкрепляется
действием на каком-то уровне,
поэтому идея поиска
разных
противоречий или разных
ретро-
подходов
может быть случаем.  вы представляете,
когда кто-то думает о том, чтобы
пройти через лес,
вы знаете, или вы могли бы заново воплотить многие из
этих вещей,
или, может быть, все на каком-то уровне
проходит через какое-то воплощение,
и когда это концептуально,
воплощение просто происходит в  более
концептуальное пространство,
гм, которое не полагается на множество других
гм историй или
ощущений, как вы проходите через вещи,
так
что разница, которая происходит, когда вы находитесь
в поле практики, заключается в том, что вы так
привыкли быть в этом  поле практики,
что
это воплощение становится водой, в которой
вы плаваете,
так что это может быть
что-то вроде того, что связано с этим
великим да, деканом, просто очень быстро, поэтому
снова мы спросим в этот момент да на
самом деле  см
да инструментализму
да до конца
нет или
отменено
у нас был маленький амперсанд здесь и
мы и здесь
эм одно краткое примечание для понимания
мы не будем вдаваться в подробности здесь, но 4e может
ссылаться на xiavio и van der
статья Шиффа 2018 года, которая была в
контексте музыкальной педагогики, что является
очень увлекательной областью 4e воплощено
встроено встроено
расширено введено в действие
инкультурировано и т. д. и т. д. и т. д. 7e 11e 22e все
они, а затем забавная цитата из Карла Фристена
из нашего
симпозиума по прикладному активному выводу в
2021 году
он сказал, что одна ключевая вещь об активном
умозаключении
заключается в том, что оно находится за пределами предсказательной
обработки, оно выходит за пределы разума, и оно
подчеркивает или отражает прагматический
поворот в начале этого века, который
действительно воплощен в четырех «е»,
чтобы прояснить, что разум
активен
и что вы говорите
о круговой причинно-следственной связи взаимодействия
с любой частицей, личной или растительной, с
чем бы то ни было, фиолетовой круговой
причинно-следственной связью, и все это влечет за собой
довольно краткое  Мы не собираемся вдаваться
в какие-либо из этих деталей, но вот
ряд работ, имеющих отношение к
неактивной статье,
просто некоторые другие справочные
цитаты и другая работа, которую можно было бы
захотеть изучить,
и для статьи о похищении,
а также  немного опираясь даже
на что-то, надеюсь, авторы смогут
раскрыть для нас роль и
связь номинализма со всем
этим, но многие предыдущие статьи
авторов здесь
перечислены, и снова много отличной работы, так что
спасибо вам, ребята, за
это путешествие
сейчас
мы можем войти в две статьи или
промежутки между ними,
давайте
проведем первоначальное сопоставление двух статей, я положу наше видео, это
будет верхушка айсберга, так что, декан,
вы - верхушка айсберга, что бы
вы хотели сказать?  об этих двух документах
в первоначальном сопоставлении,
как я уже сказал, я думаю, что
если вы действительно сделаете шаг назад и поймете,
что то, что люди делают
, соединяя их с активным выводом,
вы говорите, что
у меня есть определенный вид
ситуационного анализа, который я хотел
бы выполнить, и при этом я хотел
бы попытаться устранить противоречия или я
хотел бы
сформулировать интеграцию,
и если вы вернетесь к этому месту,
ваш
ваш пример так что ваш ваш гипер ваш
гипер гм
ваша голова ваша  предмет - это суб
ситуационный анализ,
под который ваш пример подходит, что
вы сейчас не
совершаете ошибку, говоря, что
мой способ сделать это
автоматически отрицает или превращает другие
способы смотреть на все, что
под этим заголовком, ситуационный ситуационный
анализ в пыль  теперь
есть сравнения, и они не
написаны здесь, и они настолько готовы, что
я просто выбрал примеры в
каждой из статей, где
статьи говорят о двух разных
фокусных точках, но они все еще находятся в пределах
этой более широкой
маргинальной
границы активного  умозаключение и то, как
активное умозаключение
ведет себя
вокруг поведения
в рамках режима внимания и открывает
его для чего-то более доступного,
чем  Специфика или дружественная к масштабу
вещь: обязательно ли теория разума
сочетается
с активным выводом, или
идея о том, что похищение в тот момент,
когда я прибываю, на самом деле
сводит на нет любую возможность использования
инструментов для расширения моего сенсорного
окна,
так что снова мы не собираемся тратить
много времени, чтобы
вытащить эти другие вещи, но если
люди хотят на самом деле увидеть, как, когда
вы кладете примерно две бумаги рядом друг с
другом, вы можете найти массу
сходств,
это довольно интересное упражнение, это
занимает некоторое время,
но когда вы действительно видите их  бок о бок
друг с другом и запутанные есть там
много плетения происходит
спасибо Дин Стивен
да мне нравится это
эмм как Дин говорил о там у вас
есть эти две статьи это можно почти
рассматривать как два айсберга где
их философия добрая
замороженных и
приданных форме и форме, и есть что-то
внизу и что-то наверху,
но есть также вода
между ними, в
которой может быть
много креветок и  и всевозможные
вещи плавают вокруг, так что
я думаю, что в этом списке здесь, где у
вас есть инструментализм реализма,
ну, это ваши два
айсберга, верно,
мы хотим, чтобы они были красивыми и острыми,
и, возможно, вас немного сбили, если вы
ударите  от них, а затем ладно, статистика
и сравнение моделей,
вы знаете,
они они, они все еще там, но
они могут немного добавить многоагентную
коммуникацию убеждений, о, подождите, у
нас здесь что-то течет,
вещи, как собранные ансамбли, извините,
модели, как ансамбли,
перспектива.
или перспектива колготок или откуда эти
перспективы исходят из способов познания
стохастических сложных систем
и т. д.,
мы сейчас, может быть,
я не знаю, не растворяем ли мы
айсберг, это не о том, что
айсберг есть, но мы  это
разные типы
способов, и они
начинают, возможно, быть более гибкими
и менее стабильными,
так что в неактивный документ мы идем
, чтобы все было разумно, а также
многое обсуждали в одном  и два
снова, мы поместили много контента на
слайды, чтобы вы могли сделать паузу и насладиться,
большая часть контента скопирована и процитирована
из бумаги, так что это точка
отсчета, чтобы узнать больше,
мы просто пройдемся
по порядку дорожной карты  некоторые из
ключевых
частей, которые проходят документы, поэтому
в первом разделе неактивного документа
они собираются начать с
обобщения аргумента Вессье в 2020 году о
понимании других в мире, и
это представлено в этом
документе «Размышление через другие умы».  а затем
том — теория разума,
они обобщают
или фиксируют аргумент мышления
через другие разумы как одну
предпосылку один социальное познание неактивно
и воплощено два неактивно и
воплощено социальный актор не может напрямую понять
социальное познание
три все, что не может быть непосредственно
постигнуто, должно быть выведено
ergo qed вывод о неактивном и
воплощенном социальном познании
должен быть сделан вывод о
социальном познании
и об авторах  в неактивной статье
утверждается, что по предпосылкам два и три
ttom присоединяется к ортодоксальному
пониманию мира и других к
ним, сводится к способности делать выводы
и приписывать психические состояния,
что является суммированием мышления
через другие умы,
и они собираются подвергнуть сомнению
на этом критическом
анализе, что такая учетная запись ttom действительно делает этот счастливый
брак с активизмом
они собираются тянуть да кого угодно
или продолжать ладно они собираются они
собираются они собираются тянуть несколько
разных  эти предпосылки
и какие скрытые допущения могут лежать в
основе этих предпосылок, например, какие
аксиомы приводят к созданию таких
предпосылок,
противоречие между p1 и p2 является
результатом двух скрытых допущений в
этом аргументе t2m, поэтому здесь мы видим p123
выше,
а затем скрытое допущение одно
социальное познание сводит к  информация
в явной пропозициональной форме,
ментальное представление и приписывание,
они собираются сказать это, они так
себя чувствуют как  ментальное
представление
и скрытое допущение тоже, социальное
познание жестко связано с концепциями
и логическими инструментами для вывода,
например,
при рождении,
и в последующих разделах
они собираются проанализировать и прояснить
противоречие между предпосылками один и
два,
это противоречие,
если социальное познание  активны и
воплощены
, так ли это на самом деле, или это
противоречивое утверждение,
что социальное познание не может быть непосредственно
постигнуто таким социальным актором
, который затем собирается критически оценить
с неактивной точки зрения, какие
проблемы могут лежать в основе этих
предположений, скрытых предположений и
почему  активист отвергает эти скрытые
предположения
и, следовательно, отвергает перечисленные выше предпосылки,
а затем собирается исследовать,
что это за нерепрезентативные
методы и механизмы
совместного конструирования в социальном действии,
у них есть марковское одеяло,
визуальное представление, которое мы
видели здесь раньше
с внутренними состояниями, внешними состояниями
и посредничеством в  внутренние и
внешние состояния с помощью общих состояний,
которые, согласно определению Pearl 1988,
являются общими состояниями, делающими
внутреннее и внешнее состояния
условно независимыми,
иногда люди идут дальше и
описывают фристеновское одеяло, где общие
состояния
b разделены на два типа состояний:
смысловые и активные.
и эти два вида состояний
определяются их входящими с
точки зрения внутренних состояний
статистическими зависимостями сенсорными состояниями
и исходящими статистическими зависимостями,
которые можно интерпретировать как действия или
интерфейсы
от сущности или вещи к нише,
но мы вернемся к марковским одеялам.
и больше позже,
да, Стивен, дерзайте,
просто вернитесь к этой
странице на слайде до этого,
но в отношении этого, когда он говорит, что
вещи не могут быть напрямую, есть
пара вещей, которые
сразу хорошо понимаются, я бы сказал, что с
этим это  полезное различие, потому что,
когда мы думаем о эм, мы говорим
о захвате и  рукоятку или пару
плоскогубцев, и я не могу напрямую схватить горячую
трубу, мне нужны плоскогубцы, я не могу
напрямую сделать ряд вещей, возможно, без
более чем одного инструмента,
но есть ощущение, что
когда мы говорим о захвате вещей или
когда люди думают о том,
есть
ли что-то, что вы знаете, чтобы понять что-то,
что является явно пропозициональным,
вы знаете, что у нас есть другие виды инструментов,
которые могут вступить в игру, даже когда
мы думаем о словах,
и акт приписывания
всех этих вещей может быть
перформансом с  инструменты на каждом уровне,
так что
здесь происходит интересное смешивание в
зависимости от того,
как айсберг отлично тает
во втором разделе,
который вы можете прочитать в статье или сделать паузу
здесь и зафиксировать многие аспекты этого,
они собираются подвергнуть сомнению предположение
что социальное познание сводится к ментальному
представлению,
и
их точка зрения может быть уточнена, поскольку
понимание других зависит
от умения разделять неявные значения
и, возможно, некоторых
абдуктивных
динь-динь-динь и рассуждения, основанные на модели,
все из которых являются контекстно-
зависимыми и динамичными,
и в следующих абзацах они собираются раскрыть,
что в этом
заключается очевидное противоречие между этими
первыми двумя предпосылками, которое действительно похоже
на ахиллесову пяту.  или слабое место, где
они собираются нацелиться на свою логику
во втором разделе,
они собираются подвергнуть сомнению второе
из предположений, которое состоит в том, что социальное
познание запрограммировано с рождения,
и поэтому, хотя они и определяют окончательную
позицию,
и они говорят, что vessier делает  не придерживаются
нативистской позиции, например, как
чистая врожденная точка зрения,
потому что они действительно сосредоточены на
динамике развития и экологической динамики того,
как приобретается культура,
они ставят под сомнение
приобретение стартового пакета,
и они также изучают больше в этом
разделе  некоторые инактивисты критикуют,
например, запрограммированные взгляды на социальное
познание
в разделе 3
, критикуя предположения, которые, по
их мнению, подчеркивают  противоречие,
присущее мышлению через другие
умы, они собираются предложить другое
отношение, о, вам не нравится это блюдо,
давайте попробуем это,
и это будет
подход из теории динамических систем
или dst, они пишут
dst,
как мы будем утверждать в  этот раздел представляет собой
подход, который служит для изучения и
создания предсказательной силы в отношении
социокультурно обусловленных практик
агентов, создающих свою нишу,
поскольку в основе dst лежат
полезные инструменты, такие как
нелинейность возникновения, спонтанность и т. д.,
что позволяет нам отойти от
заранее подготовленных понятий.
Поэтому следует воздерживаться от принятия
онтологических предположений
о том, как обстоят
дела в мире,
поэтому следует воздерживаться от философской онтологии,
а не от понимания управления знаниями в области компьютерных наук
об онтологии.
такого
рода онтологические допущения,
санкционированные реализмом,
относительно сложного  система, основанная на
поддающейся обработке модели,
поэтому то, что модель настолько
податлива
, не означает, что у нас есть лицензия
на онтологические предположения,
поскольку податливая модель дает
возможность узнать о
сложном поведении, разрешены только эпистемологические утверждения.
посмотрите на утверждение,
чтобы сделать его податливым, мы можем представить
динамическую систему статическими
отношениями следующим образом, и вот
их уравнения один, два и три
с подписями ниже,
и они используют эти очень
простые вроде как ядро
ческих систем  Теория — это
понимание того, как
вещи зависят от того, как они меняются в
целом, и это представлено несколькими
различными способами
в терминах модели преемника и в большей
степени модели луча изменений.
точка, потому что это также говорит
о том смысле, что
это подход к моделированию,
давайте посмотрим, что
модель говорит нам, а не подгонка модели
подход,
гм, который часто заключается в том, что вы знаете, что в конечном итоге
произойдет, если у вас есть определенная
онтология,
вы знаете, что вы эффективно знаете
так много вещей, так
что, возможно, это ключевой
элемент,
который
связывает многое из того, как вещи могут быть соединены мостом с
точки зрения активного вывода и как это
может быть
вы знаете
, что
это стойка в том смысле,
что она держит ноги врозь и
говорит:
хорошо,
я делаю шпагат или правильно ли я
свела ноги,
так что
давайте выясним, а не
вы, а кто-то эксперт, скажите мне
и
да, спасибо,
спасибо, декан, да,
да, я просто хотел добавить к тому, что
Стивен только что сказал, я
до этого момента я действительно и я
люблю статью,
что это конструктивистская статья,
хотя я думаю, что
это
заставляет меня остановиться на минуту, потому что я верю,
что  для того,
чтобы мы могли
принять это решение
, это расколы или это вилка, это
буквально вилка, и вместо того,
чтобы идти слева направо, требуется
деконструкция,
которую, я думаю, часто не учитывают
до  к реконструкции,
так что еще раз я не спорю с
авторами, потому что я думаю, что они
уважают автономию,
и я думаю, что они проделали блестящую работу,
говоря: хорошо, эта логика, этот дедуктивный
путь, который выбрали другие авторы,
может не обязательно применяться здесь  потому что
это вызывает слишком много смешивания, так что хорошо, хорошо,
хорошо, что вы держите то, что на
самом деле является левым и правым,
но вы опускаете
добавление и часть, это может быть вилка, которую
я мог бы буквально поднять, и  единственный
способ увидеть это, если вы можете
деконструировать,
прежде чем реконструировать, а деконструкция
не означает дифференцировать то, что
уже присутствует, деконструкция буквально
означает единство,
когда я прибыл в этот момент, что
у меня есть, какие части головоломки
я все еще упускаю  потому что
я тороплюсь выяснить, должен ли я
идти влево или вправо,
особенно в общем контексте, особенно
там,
да, Стивен, если вы хотите
кратко указать здесь, спасибо, просто добавлю к
этому.
эта часть ситуативности,
я
думаю, именно здесь вы приходите к
осознанию того, что происходит, поэтому наука
в значительной степени говорит нам, что происходит,
что это за вещь, что
это, что это,
но эта развилка на дороге или существо, которое вы
знаете  стык возраста команды или
что-то еще, в
конечном счете, есть часть осознания,
где это находится, и в активном
выводе, который часто более
сложен, туманен
с научным существом о
точности метода, а в
других случаях осознание и
сложность возникают в активном выводе, могут
иметь оба  те, да, отлично,
продолжая в последних частях статьи,
они много говорят о сложности, которую
многие из нас так любят,
сложность, сложность, наука,
теория сложности, приносит так много
замечательных
терминов, концепций, людей, методов, инструментов,
идей, всего,
и они много говорят об автополитике
и этой рекурсивности.  так что в неактивной статье
сделано много действительно творческих связей,
и сложность
используемые действительно ценным образом,
в четвертом разделе
они перейдут к активному
умозаключению в неактивной динамической обстановке,
и именно здесь активное умозаключение
будет развернуто в качестве проницательного
инструмента для изучения и
понимания динамики, лежащей в основе культурных
со-конструкций.
учитывая, что агенты не обязательно воспринимаются
как пассивные
агенты, вместе они являются авторами
состояний друг друга
и, таким образом,
аналогичны неактивным
фигурам, показанным ранее, где у нас были
шестерни в голове,
а затем это пошло на то, чтобы шестерни
были более распределены  в теле и
в уме
здесь, на рис. 2, больше
классического
значения и рассуждений, основанных на модели, где
различные социальные акторы как бы
имеют этот логический вывод, который
очень похож на однонаправленный, как показано здесь
со стрелкой, указывающей только на
середину и  на рисунке 3 они
изображают социальное действие на рисунке 2 при
активном выводе с точки зрения обозначения
здесь внутренних состояний.  что социальный актор
и внешние состояния являются социальным
актором один, так что это с
точки зрения социального актора два,
где общие состояния
оформляются как социокультурное значение, а
рассуждения, основанные на модели
, открываются для логических выводов
, которые распределяются
и разыгрываются
и
[Музыка]
надеюсь, мы углубимся в подробности,
потому что именно здесь они
поддерживают свое позитивное
инструменталистское применение активного
вывода в социальном неактивном пространстве,
а затем они пишут, характеризуя
социальную сцену как аналогичную научной
практике.
например, взять то, что происходит в
лаборатории в определенном контексте, и
даже определенный взгляд на то, что происходит в
лаборатории в определенном контексте,
запятую в определенном контексте,
а затем подвергнуть критике это
и немного более широко подумать
о том, что происходит в
коридорах лаборатории.  и в подвале и
в мире вокруг здания
и это тоже г  действительно хорошо связан
с каким-то желтым бронбергом вообще работа
над предвосхищающим мозгом не является
ученым, который также сосредотачивается на
неактивной перспективе с экологической
точки зрения не только обязательно
социальной, но и социальной является важным
случаем
в таблице 1, которую
они собираются обсудить  немного
больше о
некоторых делителях и содержимом
клеток, связанных с миром природы,
научными инструментами и конструкциями
, мы обязательно вернемся сюда в
последующих обсуждениях, так что просто проверьте
таблицу 1 и
посмотрите, что вы думаете,
какие другие линии вы бы хотели  нарисуйте, будут ли
они похожи на изогнутые линии,
похожие на буквы, обведете
ли вы что-нибудь, нарисуете ли вы несколько треугольников
, добавите ли вы еще одну строку, сделаете ли вы
ее тензорной, что еще вы нарисуете на
первой таблице,
даже если бы только еще одна двойная ограничивающая
линия, чтобы подчеркнуть  что это идеально,
как Дин,
все, что я хотел бы сказать, это если вы пойдете
и посмотрите на это, спросите себя, почему эти
гиперпараметры и почему
эти поздние  rals,
потому что я думаю,
что это приведет ко всему
хорошему для меня, это просто заставило меня так закрутиться
вокруг
веселья,
хорошо, а затем заключение, прежде чем мы перейдем
ко второй статье,
мы показали, что придерживание как
активизма, так и теории разума влечет за собой
противоречие и
Путаница становится очевидной, когда мы критически
анализируем два скрытых предположения, которых
придерживаются томоподобные теории, такие как ttom,
которые отвергаются инактивизмом, эти два
скрытых предположения, которые, по их мнению,
дискредитируют связь,
а затем
они повторяют соконструктивную
природу и встроенные и экологические
компоненты.  социального бездействия
, рекурсии и
развертывания во времени социального
бездействия,
и они предполагают, что теория динамических систем
и активный вывод, инструментально
применяемые в качестве типа моделирования динамических систем
, обещают
и являются подходящим и дополнительным инструментом
для рассмотрения социального понимания как
обобщенная синхронизация
проходила определенным образом,
так что p  aper, и
теперь он будет соединен
с абдуктивной бумагой, так что
один вдох, прежде чем мы перейдем к похищению,
да, Стивен переводит
дух, это последнее
предложение о том, как это может быть,
эм, почти мостом, они
дополняют друг друга, эм,
используют теорию динамических систем.
и как бы заполняет пробел, они как бы
заполняют пробел, и в каком-то смысле я думаю, что, когда
мы говорим о документе о похищении,
некоторые пробелы не заполняют,
я знаю, что мы не пытаемся говорить здесь о
заполнении пробелов, но  скажем, вы
заполняете пробелы.
Похищение
также может ощущаться, так что вы
знаете красоту красоты активного
вывода, а байесовский подход заключается в
том, что существует множество различных
масштабов и модальностей, которые можно
взвешивать и смешивать, чтобы дать вам
потенциально почувствовать,
что  поступать правильно, так
что это не означает, что одно исключает другое.
В своих целях
они заинтересованы в этом натуралистическом
представлении некоторых из более поздних работ К. С. Пирса,
например, после 1903 или после 1905 года, в
основном неопубликованных работ,
раскрывающих семиотические и логические
понятия абдуктивного рассуждения, которые мы
рассмотрели в разделе контекста, к которому
они стремятся.  биологическая
модель похищения,
которая собирается
продеть иглу,
ткать ткань, что бы это ни было,
что поддерживает функциональную
целостность организма,
эволюционный императив для
существования этого живого существа и быть
совместимым с современной неврологией,
они фокусируются на верности и
союзе, которые мы  о которых говорилось ранее,
и они также введут во
введении концепцию марковского одеяла,
которая будет отличной точкой
сопоставления, чтобы добавить немного больше
деталей, например, если это фронт контакта
с активным выводом с социальным
бездействием и похищением,
тогда эти  похожи на горячие точки или
точки соприкосновения на передней панели интерфейса, чтобы
действительно увеличить масштаб, хорошо, как  используется ли внутреннее
состояние в этих двух моделях, и
именно здесь онтология активного вывода
имеет огромную ценность, потому что
даже когда люди говорят на
разных языках или у нас есть
компьютерная программа, уравнение, стихотворение, а
затем научная статья,
когда мы можем связать и проактивно  использовать или
проактивно аннотировать с помощью
онтологии активного вывода,
мы получаем возможность не просто сказать хорошо,
мы оба указываем на луну,
это твой палец мой палец, или мы
указываем на один и тот же палец, потому что он
так далеко и, возможно, это немного
откусите, и ваш ваш луч не попадает в
луну, с моей точки зрения,
и так далее, вместо этого мы можем на самом деле
спуститься и не
истечь кровью на операционном столе,
а скорее кратковременно придавить и
найти аттрактор, который поможет нам действительно войти в
это пересечение, а не  чем просто
ударить и бежать только с точками
резонанса, Дин,
да,
я просто резюмирую это, сказав, что мы
можем лучше ситуационно анализировать, потому
что теперь мы на самом деле ч  у меня
есть способ
свести воедино
что-то общее, так что это все, что я хочу добавить к тому, что вы
только что сказали,
и просто добавить одно к этому
, да, извините, но гм,
и где может
быть разница, так что
вы знаете, как
может быть такое понимание
многих терминов, онтологическое
понимание, и сказать,
что часто возникает проблема, если есть что-
то, что не
выровнено, но
просто не замечается или игнорируется, скажем,
хорошо, это другое, хорошо, здесь есть
онтологические изменения
, есть  да, есть
способ сделать это податливым,
как у нас с активным выводом,
это податливый способ сделать это, потому что в
противном случае
в этом пространстве плавает так много онтологических вещей,
которые так красивы,
что когнитивно
невозможно найти то, что вы  нужно посмотреть еще раз
спасибо
в следующем разделе
с этими двумя источниками света,
совместно освещающими совместное построение,
никакие два источника света не могут физически перекрываться,
поэтому должен быть вызван параллакс  благодаря этим
двум светам и теням и всевозможным
эффектам, и, может быть, это не
одна и та же длина волны, и, может быть, вы идете,
и разные стороны имеют
разное освещение,
раздел находится в активном выводе
в свете похищения,
это очень
увлекательный раздел,
потому что они  Мы собираемся взять эту
почти
квазиалгоритмическую,
но определенно
предвычислительную структуру
, разработанную в конце 1800-х
и начале 1900-х годов,
и начать
интерфейс и посмотреть,
как она связана с активным выводом,
чтобы мы могли выделить больше, и мы с нетерпением
ждем обсуждения в  дальнейшие
разделы, поэтому сделайте паузу, если вы хотите
прочитать все это или прочитать статью,
но они сосредоточены на поздней схеме
да, пожалуйста, декан, все, что я хотел сказать
, это освещение настроения, если вы действительно
посмотрите вниз на нижний маркер
освещение на самом деле пытается
кошелек говорил об этом, может быть, может быть, я
не знаю, действительно ли у него были
формализмы, чтобы поддержать это,
но активный вывод действительно теперь
говорит  насчет того
уровня энергии,
который мы сейчас можем
видеть в рамках двух
ограничений, что, что, эта идея
параметризации обратно в тиски
,
спасибо, так что просто несколько цитат, которые
действительно очаровательны здесь,
так что
в науке похищение  можно
уподобить логике открытия гипотез,
которая, как мы обсуждали ранее, имеет
порождающий творческий элемент, а затем
вторичный селективный компонент, такой как
выбор байесовской модели, редукция байесовской модели,
и они даже добавляют с предостерегающим
замечанием, что полная
ассимиляция похищения Пирсона не может
произойти.  например, это вывод о
наилучшем объяснении, которое является
половиной двухтактного двигателя, и обычно
люди будут использовать абдукцию для обозначения
вероятностных рассуждений из данного набора,
как абдукция в других местах в трудах
этой более поздней схемы
те, которые после 1903 года,
но
согласно  для экспертов были наименее
исследовательскими, начиная с наблюдения
удивительного фактора e  излучает
удивление наблюдения
и через условную большую посылку
заключает в совместном настроении снова
настроение,
которое Пирс назвал исследователем,
оно такое, какое оно есть и правильное в нем,
а именно то, что необходимо сделать что-то крайне
важное
прагматизм бездействие политический выбор
изначально вызванный  любопытством
снижение неопределенности энтропия,
которая приводит к формулировке
вопроса,
который является семантическим,
и
есть больше обсуждения
исследовательского настроения и других настроений
да декан еще одна быстрая вещь,
подобранная или совместно построенная из
другой статьи, снова
разделяет общий префикс, что мы
снова  я думаю, что, возможно, смогу еще немного
подразнить
важность этого в следующих нескольких
прямых трансляциях,
они собираются продолжить этот
вопрос экономики исследований,
поэтому
они сформировали три аргументативных курса,
действительно определенные области контакта с
активным выводом.  и похищение, которое
они предлагают сформировать первоначальное трио
или триаду,
которая будет играть главную роль  t чтобы сформировать связь
между активным и абдуктивным умозаключением, во-
первых, наличие
недегенеративных тройственных отношений,
затем использование ведущих
принципов абдуктивного рассуждения
b и, в-третьих, сослагательное наклонение, условная
формулировка,
есть некоторые логические технические
детали, но для
этого и нужны потоки.
в пункте а,
который вы можете сделать паузу и прочитать текст,
они собираются выделить концепцию марковского
одеяла
или, скорее,
их реалистическую
интерпретацию как фрист и одеяла,
и
утверждать,
что марковские одеяла, снова реализованные
в реалистическом смысле,
имеют заметно пронзительный смысл.
нередуцируемая триадическая форма,
фокусирующаяся на границе как на посреднике
между внешними внутренними состояниями и,
следовательно, на третьей степени, возникающей в семиозисе
, можно сказать гораздо больше, но если кто-то
из вас захочет добавить еще один пункт к а,
они продолжат  говорить
о некоторых руководящих принципах
вывода
и, в частности, обсуждать
Роль дукции в руководстве выводом
Что является ведущим принципом активного
вывода, то
здесь они собираются описать некоторые
технические детали активного вывода с
точки зрения вариации свободной энергии или
ожидаемой неожиданности,
а затем они свяжут это с некоторыми
из основных  источники пирса и
обсуждения биосемиотики, которые
также были связаны во многих
дискуссиях, которые у нас были о
репрезентации и значении, и так далее,
и
это идет еще дальше или глубже в
обсуждениях синехизма
, а также этого
вопроса универсального разума, который  это
сила старения в некотором роде всеобщее
познание пан когнитивная динамика
распределенные когнитивные системы
материя изнеженный разум по фон шиллеру
и тогда они собираются спорить о
нетронутых одеялах и их построении
в терминах триадных отношений
триада Пирсона знак объект интерпретация муравей
ведет к неизведанному  семантические
возможности,
объединяющие некоторые из этих более широких
качественных нитей.  семиотический анализ
с потенциально динамической теорией систем,
количественные байесовские методы и
все остальное, что активный вывод
приносит вместе с инструментами для
реализации,
и посмотрите,
они также собираются раскрыть некоторые
чрезвычайно
интересные, хотя и нюансированные логические
конструктивные
элементы семиотического предложения,
если бы я мог  назовите это тем, что
углубится в это
в дальнейших дискуссиях,
но они собираются исследовать,
как различные
структуры логических отношений
между пунктами или утверждениями и
гарантиями, и вся эта риторика
связаны с
похищением реализма
и
версией реализма Пирса, поскольку
возможное - это то, что может стать реальным
да, есть вещи, которые возможны,
но не могут стать действительными, и тогда что
мы используем для этого смежного или
реализуемого
возможного
и
где мы могли бы захотеть использовать это и
что нарушит эту симметрию, где
прагматизм, ну, что было бы полезно
рассмотреть, было бы  пространство всего
возможного, что могло бы случиться и ничего
другого и n  не удивляйтесь соседним
возможностям, которые мы не учли, но
которые произошли,
и тогда, может быть, не так уж плохо
потратить немного дополнительных размышлений или несколько
дополнительных компьютерных ресурсов на рассмотрение
возможностей, которые не могли произойти,
но мы бы не хотели  потеряться в
потенциально экспоненциальном пространстве
возможностей, которые не могут произойти,
и в конечном итоге потерять наше внимание и
внимание к возможностям, которые могут
произойти, которые Пирс описывает
как реальные возможности,
а прагматическая позиция
и настроение
также замыкают петлю с
выбором политики и  прагматизм в активном
умозаключении,
где они говорят, что прагматическое
значение верований в формулировке bane paris
заключается в том, что на то, на что человек
способен действовать,
и в этом есть много резонансов,
Стивен,
да, я думаю, что это также говорит
о необходимости иметь
мы говорим о масштабировании или уровнях,
или
вы знаете какую-то структуру, которая
позволяет этому присутствовать, потому что
вы знаете, что активное влияние может так  Если мы пройдем
весь путь вниз и спустимся
на клеточный уровень, поскольку есть способы
взглянуть на это
здесь, есть ощущение, что хорошо, мы
смотрим на
эти гм-
идеи гм-означающего,
но с помощью активного вывода мы знаем,
что это не так.  считает, что у нас есть
поступающие сигналы, которые обрабатываются
и агрегируются,
так что есть своего рода шкала, на
которой у вас есть структуры, в которых у вас
есть
морфогенез, возможно, чтобы добраться
до шкалы, чтобы
сделать знак стоп
интерпретируемым как его  собственное
означающее, поэтому я думаю, что это может быть то место, где
будет происходить это напряжение
между неактивистами здесь, и
где это может произойти, но аргумент
вполне может быть, я бы сказал, что определенные
масштабы
определенные структуры
и, возможно, определенные реалистичные
способы происходящего,
что-то вроде
это возможно,
просто отлично, декан, и тогда мы быстро
пройдемся по остальным, позвольте мне быть
очень быстрым здесь, я думаю, особенно в b
и и до меньшей степени и
c автобус  То, как мы переносим пронзающее
мышление
в область активного вывода,
построено на предположении,
что продолжение нашего продолжающегося
существования нашей продолжающейся
реальности
означает, что мы накапливаем больше
опыта с инструментами
в мире, правилами в мире.  мир
и пулы, и под пулами я имею в виду те
скопления, на которые Стивен только что
указал, спасибо за то, что вы
подняли это, Стивен, потому что это заставило меня захотеть
записать эти скопления как
рассказ о двух плотностях, материализующихся,
так что еще раз я не знаю,
что вы
исключительно говорят, что все реально, и
тогда все примеры под этим
также реальны, потому что даже сам Пирс
сказал, что есть аспект этой
реальности, который мы никогда
не сможем описать как что-либо кроме
нереальности,
даже если мы в основном используем
так как же это,
как это
позволяет этим плотностям формироваться, и я
знаю, что это звучит чертовски чертовски и
ушло туда,
извините, но это  на самом деле то, что мы
должны обдумать,
спасибо, что
они собираются
перевернуть сценарий или, по крайней мере, синтаксис
и говорить о похищении в свете
активного вывода,
вот где они начинают с этого
признания двухтактного двигателя
с генеративным похищением и  выборочное
похищение,
а затем они собираются связать это
с некоторой онтологией активного
вывода в терминах, например, видения
избирательного похищения
как процесса выборки
и понимания того, где
вписывается генеративное похищение,
так что продолжая рассматривать похищение
в свете активного вывода, который
мы могли бы даже операционализировать, говоря,
что
фреймирование или рассмотрение похищения
с точки зрения
онтологии активного вывода
, а не самовыбор
как интерпретация активного вывода как
некоторого
понятия, которое мы не можем обязательно
говорить для понятия, которое
мы не можем говорить по-английски, но  мы можем
использовать английские слова
и, таким образом, нам не нужно
обязательно говорить для активной информации
хотя я последний, кто сказал, что они
должны или не должны
делать, можно
использовать активную онтологию вывода, а
затем это похоже на двухэтапный
контрольный список, который
был термином в акте
онтологии вывода в основном дополнении или
влечет за собой разделы,
было ли оно
использовано прагматичным образом, имело ли
смысл в этой ситуации
в этом многомасштабном контексте,
и это на самом деле двухэтапный процесс,
чтобы спросить, говорим ли мы,
используя активный вывод, а не
говорим ли мы для  как защитник или
как продавец для активного вывода
как такового,
и они собираются переформулировать дело с
точки зрения структуры fap в
смысле и с использованием терминов,
и они собираются выделить
связь внутренних состояний
с внешними.  состояния, опосредованные через
одеяло,
и затем они проходят через этот силлогизм
, реструктурируют и переформулируют свою
качественную схему абдуктивного активного
вывода,
и они описывают эту
петлю восприятия познания действия,
где  воспринимают любую входящую
сенсорную информацию,
а затем
принимают ее не только в пассивную
или даже активную интерпретацию
в контексте байесовской генеративной
модели,
но скорее в то, что разворачивается
в том настроении исследователя, которое
они продолжают
и привносят.  э-э, важная пронзительная
идея экономики исследований,
так что мы вернемся к этому снова, надеюсь,
с авторами. м-м,
это относится к теории
науки
Пирса.
между полезностью
и затратами,
и, в частности, это будет
связано с исследованием в этом социально
принятом прагматическом смысле
, задаваясь вопросом, как, учитывая затраты денег,
времени и энергии,
что
получит наиболее ценное
дополнение к знанию, к
какому эксперименту, к которому мои глаза могли бы
приблизиться,  получить наибольшее количество информации,
какие эксперименты мог бы
провести исследователь, чтобы уменьшить свою неуверенность
больше всего о естественной системе
не только для того, чтобы проверить то, что они знают,
не просто для того, чтобы фальсифицировать то, что, как
они знают, будет фальсифицировано, но и для того,
чтобы существовать в этом оптимальном экспериментальном
пространстве,
а затем пронзить, а позже авторы
собираются натурализовать контекстуализировать
довести до социального  когнитивной области
, задав вопрос, как возникают деньги, время и
энергия, потому что этот оптимальный
эксперимент проводится в культуре, и он использует
энергию, использует реагенты, поэтому, возможно,
таким образом мы могли бы сказать, что Пирс был
одним из первых современных менеджеров программ
для крупного финансирующего агентства, но  нет,
он не был, и они обсудили эту
экономию исследований немного больше,
они описывают в этом разделе,
как Пирс
продвигает несколько
ценностей, достоинств или качеств,
которые характеризуют экономию
научной гипотезы
в сложности,
что похоже на снижение риска в
широте,
которая говорит о  унификация
и осторожность
как экономическое качество избегания
убывающей предельной отдачи за
счет умелого взлома.  разбить вопросы
на серию небольших вопросов, на которые
можно ответить с разумными
ограничениями инвестиций
сколько интересных потоков
собирается вместе
например вопросы, которые
разбиты на бинарные да вопросы не
могут быть связаны с теорией информации
и квантовой а также
здесь декан  я позволю вам
говорить
честно, я просто прочитаю это, чтобы быть честным, и, как
кратко в начале этой статьи
, нет инструменталистских
интерпретаций fep и его
ингредиентов, таких как марковские одеяла,
но
это сноска в этой статье, но наша
вера  для одного из лучших слов и
реалистичных подтверждений fep как его корней
в прагматическом прагматическом оптимизме или,
скорее, в его акте амелиаризма о
выгодах от союза между
эволюционно полезными
процессами, чтобы способствовать максимальному
выживанию,
если этот прагматический подход к реализму не
нравится возвышенным.  вкус того, кто
ищет какие-то стойкие метафизические
критерии, пусть тысяча
цветов бл  oom я думаю, что очаровательно
в этом то, что
придерживаться идеи о том, что существует реализм
, очень легко защитить позицию,
но даже на предыдущем слайде одна
из вещей,
о которых
говорилось сначала, не говоря об этом
прямо или, по крайней мере, не в  эти цитаты
заключались в том
, что эта оптимальная позиция является неким
элементом эксплуатации, или экономии,
или простоты, или кто-то сделал это
до меня, так
это то, что сокращение
и исследование, которое, как правило, занимает
больше времени, требует больше
проб и ошибок,
но также не заставляет вас
постоянно перенастраивать
к конкретному результату,
так
что это реальность,
и опять же, я бы не стал отказываться
от утверждения, что в этой игре есть очень
реальная
часть,
как минимум две, идущие вперед и
назад в этом,
так что
я  не просто на самом деле я полностью согласен с
этими авторами, как я полностью согласен
с другими авторами
в отношении идеи совместной конструкции, поэтому я
не знаю, что
вы, вы, вы,
вы обязательно запутались, если  вы
можете сказать да, и да, и снова да,
Стивен,
да, как бы добавляя к тому, что там говорится,
и идея
внедрения или
эксплуатации определенно упоминается,
и в науке
есть
эксперименты - это своего рода способ
получения знаний,
но есть часть исследования и
я бы сказал, что
вы не можете получить
исследование как таковое в пределах
объективной области, должно быть это
путешествие в
перформативное субъективное в субъективное
лиминальное,
как это сделал Эйнштейн со своими играми разума,
и вы создаете эти виды
умственных конструкций таким образом, что часть
того, что происходит сегодня, представляет собой
смесь этого, а затем это возвращается
и моделируется, экспериментирует с чем угодно,
так что я думаю, что моделирование
интересно, потому
что это как бы может прийти в этом
путешествии  немного также,
так
что это может быть что-то, что
эксперименты не могут сделать,
вот краткое изложение старой шутки, которую человек
говорит,
и ссылка  eree говорит, что вы правы, человек
b говорит b, судья говорит, что вы правы,
а человек c говорит, что да, a и b не могут быть
правы, и судья говорит, что вы знаете,
что вы правы
, это немного быстрого юмора для тех, кто
любит это  жанр,
затем у них есть заключительный раздел,
и
у нас есть много вопросов и моментов, которые нужно
сделать, и много связей, чтобы
вернуться
ко многим натурализациям здесь,
таким как поля в работе Левина,
и они даже доводят это до
регенеративных способностей плоских червей, так что
от
плоских червей до соседей по квартире
, вот куда мы идем сегодня,
а затем мы также сохранили для точки
одно сопоставление концепции марковского
одеяла, в
частности социальных и активных компонентов
науки, которые очень важны, и
Маджид привел к этим
прежние обсуждения — отличная
точка соприкосновения с абдуктивной бумагой,
а социальные неактивные бумажные
одеяла Маркова представляют собой очень
ограниченный, даже технический
контактный фронт, который обеспечит много
дискуссий.  Ион в точке один,
и именно здесь
мы закрываем точку ноль
, э-э,
снова так много отличной основы и
упаковки рюкзаков Дина и Стивена, так
что есть ли что-нибудь еще, что вы хотели бы добавить
в этот момент, или что-то возникающее, что
вы хотите обсудить  в точку один, да,
Дин, тогда Стивен, если хочешь, Даниэль,
фантастическая работа, мы только что сделали на порядок больше 3 по
сравнению с тем, что обычно было
одной бумажной прямой трансляцией, и мы все равно
получили ее менее чем за два часа, так что
ты  за это аплодируют, а
во-вторых, я просто хочу
, может быть, немного подсказки для
точки, есть исследование по
имени Исраэль Исраэль Нуньес, который говорит о
том, хотите ли вы иметь возможность
взглянуть на то, как вещи деконструируются  и
построить, вы должны посмотреть на оба
продукта в процессе, например, как
я строю автомобиль
и перерабатываю в продукте,
что это за вещь, которая является либо точкой
ветвления,
либо фактической посудой,
и поэтому, если вы откроете свой разум
для  как та инверсия
по той  континуума,
он открывает всевозможные возможности
с точки зрения приведения вещей в место,
где они не обязательно вступают в
конфликт, да, они могут интегрироваться в косу,
и, возможно,
после сегодняшнего дня это будет
чем-то, что люди, которые используют
активный вывод, который, по моему мнению,  мнение - это
и продукт, и процесс, и процесс, и
продукт
одновременно, это захват
и захват, может быть, они, может быть,
поразмыслят над ними,
это почти как прагматик, который видит
развилку на дороге и использует ее,
и, может быть, вы  используйте вилку, идя в одну
сторону, и, возможно, вы ее подбираете, может быть,
вы используете ее, завершая сервировку
стола для кого-то еще, кто будет там обедать,
и поэтому существует так много способов использования,
потому что использование
социально инсценировано, абдуктивно
контекстуализировано и т. д.
и снова в  развилка
— это место, где происходит этот разговор,
и на нашей полевой площадке или в базовом лагере
мы можем представить себе развилки и
дороги, которые встретятся, Стивен,
да, а затем в  точечный один
из способов найти способ
привести авторов, если кто-то там, вы
знаете, в небольшом путешествии, может быть, вниз по
одной из развилок, может быть, он ведет к
краю озера, и нам нужно войти
и немного промокнуть,
так как  Может ли научное
похищение или какие-то более
научно
обоснованные модели править, подтвержденные
экспериментами и инструментами? Хорошо,
когда
когда это отодвигается?
интересно, это
то, что вы, возможно, захотите подумать о
том, как мы можем
дать
какие-то четкие
варианты пути, чтобы они могли
немного отойти, не застряв
в зыбучих песках или не
утонув в глубокой воде.
Итак, мы хотим ориентироваться,
но я думаю, что это дает
некоторые из тех указателей, о которых я думаю,
где есть
своего рода
съезды с waze, а также  на пандусах, так что
спасибо,
спасибо, ребята,
это было огромно, я действительно очень ценю
всю вашу помощь,
прекрасные времена, увидимся в кукле, которую
вы